there is a world beyond yours beyond
Nations justice and ethics it never
sleeps it exists everywhere and once you
enter and there is no going back
you are agent 47 the world's premier
assassin
you can get to anyone anywhere on the
globe
no target is safe to the public victor
novokov is a well-known August in
reality he is one of the ringleaders in
an enigmatic spy ring called Iago they
deal in his secrets that unseat
governments and get people killed and
they are about to compromise covert
operatives in a major European country
time is of the essence Viktor Novikov
must be eliminated
the essence of a sandbox game like
hitman is freedom of approach where you
go how you infiltrate who you become
knowing which disguises give you access
is key but beware some individuals are
more observant than others be prepared
to improvise as you experiment with your
play style wheel awesome each hitch can
go from bloody murder
to a genuine masterpiece of
assassination
complete mastery of a level is rewarded
as your skills evolve over time
so do your options prepare equipment in
advance and plan the perfect hit new
locations will appear over time you will
travel the world new missions new
targets some targets only ever surface
once for a limited time
they are going for
and when you think you're ready to be a
contender contracts mode has evolved
within the deepest most expansive hitman
sandboxes yet mark your own targets
and share them with your friends
a challenge a world of assassins
welcome to a world of assassination it
is ever expanding ever dangerous it will
never stop challenging you